>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Thank so
much, Gabriel and everyone else
and Melodias Borinqueñas
for a beautiful concert.
You guys are clearly way up there
in terms of skill level and in terms
of taste, what you
might call or something.
Just beauty of every
sort in your performance.
>> Daniel Muñoz: Thanks so much.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Thanks
so much for that.
Thanks for working for 25 years to
-- just to come here to the Library
of Congress, this concert today.
>> Gabriel Muñoz: I think I
can die in peace after this.
>> Daniel Sheehy: There you go.
Beautiful, but don't do it.
So can we start with
who is Gabriel Muñoz?
Who is that person?
If you were somebody
else and they asked you
who Gabriel Muñoz was,
what would you say?
>> Gabriel Muñoz: It's
such a complex question,
but as some of you already know,
I was born in Hatillo
[spelling?], Puerto Rico.
I guess to find a better
life, my parents moved
to New Jersey, where I was raised.
The most difficult question I
always have to answer is how I ended
up playing this instrument
and furthermore having a
passion and love for it?
I have no clue.
I'll be honest with you.
Being raised over here
since the age of two,
it still baffles me how
I ended up doing this.
I can, however, say that it was --
basically began with watching
someone play at the age of 14,
and I've never seen this instrument
in front of me physically,
only on old cassettes or such
that my father would play
the old jíbero music,
and it kind of fascinated me, but
I didn't understand what it was.
Once I saw it, it enchanted
me instantly.
I loved the whole chorus
effect, natural chorus effect
that the instrument had and
how it portrayed itself.
It just stood out on its own,
and I felt like I really --
I really want to do that.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Well we're all
thankful that you decided that.
That was a good moment for us.
You go back to Hatillo
[spelling] at all?
>> Gabriel Muñoz: Yeah.
At the age of ten, my Dad
started taking me back
so that I would know my family,
my grandmother and grandfather
on his side and such, and every
so often, every couple of years,
I continued going back until I was
old enough to travel on my own,
and to this day, I still go.
Now, I go -- it's at the point
where I go, and it's just meeting
with different cuartristas and
playing and playing and playing.
When I get the chance,
I'll see the family,
but now it's just I'm
always playing now.
So -- but yeah, it's
always fun to go back
and recharge my cultural batteries
and musical batteries and meet
up with a lot of great
musicians over there.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Let me ask you.
Who is on those cassettes
that your father played?
Do you know at this point in time?
Who were your -- who would
you go back and meet with?
Where did you get this -- where
do you recharge your batteries,
with whom?
>> Gabriel Muñoz: I remember my
father playing a lot of cassettes
from the late great
cuatro player Maso Rivera,
which is one of the biggest pioneers
on the real typical
folklore music on the cuatro.
It had such -- I guess I would
interpret it as some type
of jíbero-funk type feel with it
that really brought out the pride
of the music in itself,
and that's someone
that I never had the opportunity
to meet before he passed away
but till this day one of the
biggest inspirations on --
the whole reason for me really
wanting to push out on the culture
with the music was Maso Rivera.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Maso Rivera.
And so what about Ladi
[Ladislao Martínez]
>> Gabriel Muñoz: Ladi
-- I consider Ladi
to be the godfather
of the modern cuatro.
La D is the person who made
the modern cuatro famous,
the ten strings, the shape, all
this came through evolution.
I understand that cuatro had
different looks throughout the years
since its creation, but Ladi
deserves so much in my perspective
so much reverence and
honor for what he did
in modernizing the instrument itself
and style of technique he used
to play and the music he used.
He composed so many songs, so
many songs, hundreds of songs
that until this day are standards
for cuatritas to learn from.
I can never go without
mentioning Ladi.
To this day, we still try,
try to learn one or two
of his songs and perform.
Like I said, he's the
godfather of the modern cuatro.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Well now
that we're on the cuatro,
tell us about the cuatro.
For someone who's never seen
the cuatro, doesn't know it.
Why -- first of all, the ten
strings and it's called cuatro.
What's that all about?
>> Gabriel Muñoz: Yeah.
I mean, there's -- I've heard
so many different stories
in Puerto Rico and over here
about how the Puerto Rican cuatro
had evolved and has evolved.
One of the things was
what you just mentioned.
Why cuatro?
Cuatro means 'number
four' in Spanish.
So one of the things I learned
was that it had four strings
when it first started evolving.
As time went by, I guess
with different artisans
and luthiers experimenting, making
instruments, they decided to make
or add strings, change the shape.
To this day, even in this year 2016,
I see different luthiers
experimenting with different styles,
shapes and looks -- adding
strings, removing strings.
A lot of the times it's just a
preference of the musician himself.
Ladi, for example, he
asked for ten strings.
There's another cuatrita
by the name of --
known as Totas Feliciano
[spelling?].
He was one of the original pioneers
of where the cuatro hadn't even
evolved yet, had four strings,
six strings, eight strings, and as
these guys went along, they added,
modified - but Ladi really made the
ten-string popular, the violin look
with the ten strings was the
modern cuatro that Ladi made.
>>Daniel Sheehy: The
violin look, with the...
>> Gabriel Muñoz: Yeah.
The violin with the -- as
European music influenced a lot
in Puerto Rico, the jíbaro, as we
call [him] wanted to feel some sense
of sophistication, some sense of
acceptance in the higher class,
and they kind of copied
the violin shape
since that represented the violin,
a lot of the classical music
and modern style, higher class
music and so the countrymen,
the peasant of Puerto Rico thought,
"hey, that shape signifies this."
And they wanted to add to
that so they figured that's
where Ladi made this famous with
the modern Puerto Rican cuatro.
>> Daniel Sheehy: So,
as far as you know.
Ladi was the one who really made
that the standard, that shape there?
>> Gabriel Muñoz: Yeah, once -- I
can't tell you he specifically asked
for this shape, but I
do know that once Ladi -
Ladi Martinez is his full name
- once Ladi started coming
out on the radio performing live,
people would hear him
all over the island.
He was one of the first ones to
come out on the air performing.
Everyone around the island wanted
to know what was that cuatro,
that instrument he was playing.
Once they saw it, everyone's
baffled, and it just kind
of took off like wild fire.
Everyone ordering cuatros
made the same way,
and it became the standard
cuatro after Ladi.
>> Daniel Sheehy: And I think
didn't he have two cuatros
in his ensembles?
>> Gabriel Muñoz: Yeah.
It was Ladi and he had a
cousin named Sarrail Archilla,
if I'm not mistaken,
one of his own cousins
that would play harmony
to his songs....
>> Anibal Ortiz: Duo?
>> Gabriel Muñoz: His duo,
yeah, to all his pieces.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Do you
ever do that yourself or --
you had one cuatro [inaudible]?
>> Gabriel Muñoz: Yeah.
We predominantly tend
to have the one cuatro,
but once in a while
we'll get together
with another fellow cuatro player
and try to work on a double -
two-part piece or something.
>> Daniel Sheehy: What
are the advantages
of having just one cuatro?
>> Gabriel Muñoz: I guess you
have more room to improvise
and to just have fun and let go,
sort of like what I do on stage.
When you have two cuatros
and you have to kind of try
to stay organized section just to
harmonize with the second cuatro.
>> Daniel Sheehy: So we're talking
about the cuatro [inaudible].
Can you just give a
little sound or tell us --
people who might not have heard
this before or close up like this?
>> Gabriel Muñoz: Yeah,
well what I love
about this instrument also I
consider the 12-string guitar,
the American guitar,
12 steel string.
It has -- being that
the strings are doubled,
it kind of gives a
natural chorus effect.
You see a lot of rock guitars
and such that will plug
up to an amplifier, let's
say, or an effects pedal,
and it'll add a chorus effect.
This has a natural --
a chorus effect just
by having the double strings
as also the 12-string guitar,
which is something
that just fascinates me
and so this is what it sounds like.
[Plays a chord.] So
it's difficult to tell,
but if you have the patience
and the ear to listen to it,
the waves kind sort of -- the
sound waves sort of go like this,
and you can kind of feel
that vibration as opposed
to a single string -- if I were
to play [plays single string]--
if I'm playing the double,
it has sort of a more
robust or fuller sound.
And that's something that always
stuck in my ear when I would watch
or listen to anyone play.
My thing is to listen
to their technique.
How do they use that
to their advantage?
And that kind of resonates
with me the most.
One of which is Edwin Colón Zayas
that has practically dominated
almost every genre that exists
for the Puerto Rican cuatro.
His technique is beyond phenomenal.
And that's something that I always
pay attention to when I watch people
and listen to people play.
How do they use that to
their advantage, of course,
using their own technique.
Every musician developed
their own style and technique.
And Edwin has kind of
dominated every part
of the cuatro to this day.
>> Daniel Sheehy: When you play the
Bach, for some reason my mind jumped
to his version of "The
Flight of the Bumble Bee."
>> Gabriel Muñoz: Yes.
Yes. Exactly.
Like I said, he's kind of dominated
everything since the 80s, I believe.
Edwin has been tinkering
with classical music,
and every time he puts an album
out, there's always a classical song
in there, one or two, and it's
just his way of saying, hey,
the Puerto Rican cuatro can be
mainstream, it can be used for this.
It's inspiring the rest of us.
>> Daniel Sheehy: What's
your message
when you include a Bach
Suite, for example, cello?
>> Gabriel Muñoz: Basically, I
would say I'm kind of going off
of what Edwin and several
other cuatro players have done.
I don't like to keep the
cuatro inside this box
where it's predominantly just
mountain music, using Christmas time
for like what we consider Christmas
caroling, what we know as parandas
and it's just jamming,
and we're going house
to house Christmas caroling and
that's it the rest of the year
because this instrument is basically
most popular at Christmas time.
But I like where a lot
of cuatritas are going,
where they're just
taking it out of that box
and say here, there's
some bluegrass.
Here's some R and B.
Here's some classical.
Here's this, here's that.
And I kind of like the
idea and the concept
of making it a little bit more
mainstream because I feel,
obviously, it'll reach
more cultures, more people
and say hey here's
this instrument just
in case you didn't know it existed.
>> Daniel Sheehy: You lived in New
Jersey for a long time now, right?
>> Gabriel Muñoz: Yes, sir.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Yomo
Toro, you run across him?
>> Gabriel Muñoz: I
had the opportunity
of meeting him on two occasions.
He did -- he frequented New Jersey
a lot, and he did come to my area
in Trenton where I reside,
to perform on two occasions.
I had the -- I didn't have the
privilege and honor of performing
with him, but I got to
sit and watch this great,
great legend and master perform.
I'll be honest with you.
I wouldn't want to
even take my instrument
out of the case in front of him.
I mean, it's just I
honored him so much.
He's always another inspiration
with his style and genre tapping
into the salsa world, something that
I believe he made popular with a lot
of old school salsa singers,
Celia Cruz, Willie Colon
and La Fania All Stars Group
that was formed in the 70s.
I remember the story
of him being requested
at the recording studio
for a salsa album.
They told him bring
the electric guitar.
Bring your friend or we're going to
put some rock guitar into the salsa.
Give it some kind of fusion.
The day comes to record, and
Yomo shows up at the studio
with his cuatro on his back.
And Willie Colon, one of the
producers of the album said,
"We're not recording
Christmas music.
This isn't jíbaro music
from the mountains."
And Yomo says, "I'm a cuatro player.
This is what I play."
The rest was history.
He made that popular
everywhere he went.
I mean, they traveled the world,
Africa, Japan, you name it.
And the cuatro was front and center
with that, and it's people like that
that we have to give thanks to,
younger generation
of cuatro players.
We know that there's that
opportunity out there.
>> Daniel Sheehy: That's
a good topic right there.
Can you tell us -- I mean,
you're in circulation.
You go around and hear
different groups
and they hear you,
and you meet people.
What is happening with the
younger generation and the cuatro?
>> Gabriel Muñoz: I'm kind of on the
fence on the growth of the cuatro.
I obviously see more
popularity of the cuatro
on the island, in Puerto Rico.
There's -- schools are
starting to make it part
of the curriculum now
to learn the cuatro.
There's a young man by the
name of Pablo Hernandez.
He's the first in history to
graduate with a Bachelor degree --
Bachelor's degree on the Puerto
Rican cuatro with a concentration
in jazz, just a month ago in
Puerto Rico, and they're starting
to make it a curriculum now which
is something I'm very proud to know,
and I'm glad to be
alive during this time
where this is coming into fruition.
I wish that over here in the States
more younger people would get
involved not necessarily just
learning to play the instrument,
but at least learn about it and
learn the culture and be involved
with it so that we can pass this
heritage down to our children.
>> Daniel Sheehy: New
Jersey and New York,
I think have probably been
important places for the cuatro
and jíbaro ever since Ladi
was around there, right?
It was a major hit
and galvanized people
and raised their Puerto Rican sense
of self, identity and dignity.
Do you have -- say you
want to renew your roots.
Are there people in New
Jersey, New York, Hartford,
Connecticut, Chicago or --
>> Gabriel Muñoz: Yeah.
There's quite a few.
They're sparse but
there's quite a few.
There's a small community, and
I try my best to try to network
with as many as I can to
keep it going, share music.
We sit down and "Hey,
you teach me this song.
I'll teach you that song.
You teach me this riff.
I'll teach you that riff."
Just to stay inspired.
It also keeps you motivated
when you're surrounded
by that type of atmosphere.
You as a musician -- everyone
gets an inspiration, a motivation,
an idea, a thought from
someone else or somewhere else,
so we try to always keep a close
knit relationship with a lot
of -- especially New York.
New York is, I believe, is really
crowded with a lot of cuatro players
and people that are involved
somehow directly or indirectly
with the music of the
Puerto Rican cuatro.
So we try to reach out to
as many as we possibly can.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Let me ask you.
This is a little bit of an
abstract question, but you've played
and learned in Puerto Rico,
and you've played and learned
in New Jersey and New
York, around there.
How is it different?
Is it different?
Is there a different
feeling or different music?
>> Gabriel Muñoz: Yeah, there is.
We actually talk about that a lot.
The styles and techniques
are a bit different.
Melodies are a bit different in
Puerto Rico then it is over here.
Being raised over here, my
influences would be Jimmy Hendrix,
things more popular over here;
whereas over there they live,
eat and breathe this
instrument 24/7 and everyone
that has played before them.
So they're what I would like
to consider much more hard core
when it comes to the
cuatro, and I hear it.
I'm like they have such a
wonderful flavor to their music,
such a wonderful flavor that
we try to imitate to the best
of our ability being
that we're over here.
We have the privilege and honor
of having good rapport with a lot
of musicians in Puerto Rico.
And so they have no problem with
sharing with us anytime we call
or share videos or
phone calls and ideas.
"Hey, you did something
on this video that I saw.
You played this song.
How do you do that?"
And we have no problem sharing.
"Say, hey, listen.
I'm going to send you the music.
I'll send you the video.
Just grab your cuatro.
We'll be over the phone.
We'll just do it over the phone."
So we have that advantage.
But yeah, the sound's
a little bit different.
The techniques are a
little bit different
from over here and over there.
But generally, cuatro players
and also guitar players
that accompany the cuatro
for the most part try
to imitate whatever we can from
the island, which is more pure.
>> Daniel Sheehy: They borrowed a
bit, though, in Puerto Rico, right?
Like from the joropo from
Venezuela or Colombia?
>> Gabriel Muñoz: Yeah.
There's a major --
>> Daniel Sheehy: You
got [inaudible].
>> Gabriel Muñoz: There's so
many influences in Puerto Rico.
There's so much to grab from.
There's so much to grab from with
the pasida [spelling?], the joropo,
the valse, the paso doble, the
mazurka, what we interpret it today.
There is so much to grab for, and
there's a little bit of influence,
so much, so many different countries
in South America in different areas,
and this kind of evolved
into this wonderful thing
where we feel we can make
it our own for the cuatro,
and like I mentioned earlier,
we like to consider the
dansa sort of classical form.
To me, it's one of the
higher end class of music,
sort of like ballroom dancing and
stuff like that, and the same thing
with the valse and the mazurka .
These are styles and genres
of music that, I really feel,
you have to put your pants on
right and learn them properly
and interpret them right.
Before or after our performance
today, I was approached by a woman
that said "I'm a classical
guitarist,
and I saw you play this classical
piece," and she was complimenting.
And I said, "You know what?
Thank you for telling me that
now and not before I played.
I would have felt so much
more pressure knowing
that there's an actual classical
guitarist in the midst."
So it's those styles of music
that we take from every country
and have become our own throughout
the years because of people
like Ladi, because of people
like Maso or Yomo Toro
and these cuatro players
of the old guard
that have made those
standards for us.
>> Daniel Sheehy: At some point,
we should turn to the music.
I had one other -- just
to continue on the --
what the cuatro means to you:
When you were explaining
how you play a string,
and there's that double little
bit of a vibration that's created
by the two almost the same pitches.
Also it's against your
body, and I'll just --
my own impression when you're
on the stage performing
you're really in yourself.
You're in a world there.
Can you either remember
a time before
where you suddenly felt really
moved or what -- tell us about that.
>> Gabriel Muñoz: Yeah.
I guess I try to focus
and concentrate
on my most intimate
moments with the instrument.
It's so simple for us
as instrumentalists
of any instrument whether it's
the cuatro guitar, piano, violin,
clarinet, doesn't matter.
We are -- or even vocal singer --
we do our best when we're alone,
when we're in private
when no one's watching.
There's no pressure.
Even in the shower.
I sing better in the shower.
You'll never hear me
in public, for example.
So I try to zone in and hone
in on those moments in my mind
and in my emotions while I'm
playing of the most intimate moments
so that it will, I guess level
my comfort zone to try to focus
on my mission, which is to try
to make you feel what I'm feeling
while I'm playing which is to try
to make you think about where
I'm taking you through my music
and why and when and where.
And I feel that it'll resonate more
with your memory and your heart
that you walk away
with an experience
and not just entertainment.
And so when I perform, my
ultimate goal essentially is
to do just that exactly.
Just try to resonate my thoughts,
feelings, emotions at that moment.
And again, I zone into those
intimate moments when I'm
in my room, for example, my
bedroom either composing a piece
or just playing something I've
played a thousand times before.
Did I play it differently this time?
Did you understand it?
Did you appreciate it?
Why and how?
Because those are the type of
moments that resonate with me
with other cuatro players.
I walk away with an experience.
I remember that more than just being
entertained, just putting on a show.
I can talk to him here
over their playing,
but you're not doing anything.
It's just entertainment.
But when you have my full
complete focus on you,
it's because you're doing
something through the instrument
and so that's what
ultimately my goal is.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Do you --
are those feelings different
when you play in Puerto Rico then
when you play in New
Jersey or New York or...
>> Gabriel Muñoz: Yeah.
When I have -- I have to admit.
When we're visiting the island,
it's such a different spirit
that just comes over us when we're
playing, specifically when we meet
up with other cuatritas or
guitarists that are known for this
because you're trying to exactly
emotionally connect with that person
and so when we're back here,
back home in the States,
we're trying to re-enact that,
if you will, and we try to live
that moment that we had in front of
you here so that you can try to get
that interpretation of what it
is we're doing in Puerto Rico,
what the music is doing over there.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Turning
to the music a bit here.
You mentioned the aguinaldo
genre as the bedrock
of some of things you play here.
Tell us about some of the
other genres, valse and dansa
and those kinds of things.
>> Gabriel Muñoz: As I said
prior, the dansa is one
of the most beautiful, beautiful
forms that exists for the cuatro.
My dream is to eventually record an
album where it's nothing but dansas.
One of the most beautiful
things ever heard
on the Puerto Rican cuatro.
It wasn't originally the dansa
particularly wasn't originally
created for the cuatro,
by the cuatro.
It was an orchestra type arrangement
played on piano and horns and such.
But as time went by and the cuatro
started becoming more mainstream
in the late 1800s and things
like that, early 1900s,
and what Ladi did do it, for
example, I'll go back to that.
The dansa became more
and more and more.
And such -- the same thing
with the valse, the same thing
with the mazurka, the same
thing with the joropo.
Each style is in its own
world but still stands
out in its own form of class.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Could you
introduce your colleague
and maybe give us a taste of
alguinaldo and then a seis or two
and then maybe a dansa,
whatever you're moved to --
>> Gabriel Muñoz: Yeah.
This is Anibal Ortiz,
our group guitarist.
We've been playing together for
approximately ten years now.
And the moment we started
playing we instantly clicked.
Being that Anibal also plays
a little bit of cuatro,
so he's familiar with the style.
He has that in his ear already,
which he translates to the guitar
and I believe perfect
accompaniment on many instances.
And yeah, we would love to try to go
through maybe a couple
of different --
>> Daniel Sheehy: Yeah, just a
little taste, a little sample.
>> Gabriel Muñoz: A couple genres.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Gives a
sense of how they're different.
>> Gabriel Muñoz: Yeah.
So here we'll do the alguinaldo
"Auro Que Venyo" [spelling?]
and it basically goes like -- which
is like you said earlier is sort
of a bedrock standard on the
cuatro for the troubadour to sing.
It goes like this.
[ Music ]
>> Daniel Sheehy: Beautiful to hear
musicians who play together a lot.
There's this messaging going on and
it can be very subtle sometimes.
>> Gabriel Muñoz: As I said
earlier, we connect pretty well
when we play the music being that we
have such a profound understanding
of what it's meant to do, not
just how it's supposed to sound,
but what it's meant to do and so
that helps the entire
experience basically.
>> Daniel Sheehy: And
that alguinaldo,
"Auro Que Venyo" [spelling]
identifies
with a certain town in Puerto Rico?
>> Gabriel Muñoz: Exactly.
Exactly. Yeah.
In Puerto Rico, there's different
genres named after different towns,
and I'm assuming because a certain
cuatrita might have created it
who lives in that town and
named it after the town.
There's a town called
Comerio in Puerto Rico,
and they have a seis
which sounds like this.
[ Music ]
>> Gabriel Muñoz: So that's another
example that seis, particular seis
where the troubadour sings
to came from that town,
and likewise many other
towns have their own version
of different alguinaldos and seis,
which are the two predominant.
>> Daniel Sheehy: What's a seis?
>> Gabriel Muñoz: A seis-- all
right, now you're going to get me
into history lesson here.
>> Daniel Sheehy: No, not too deep.
>> Gabriel Muñoz: I know that seis,
the reason they're called
seis is there's rules
and regulations to
singing these songs.
It's customary in traditions.
It has to be a certain
amount of syllables,
certain words have to rhyme.
Others don't.
Not everyone can sing --
formally sing this kind of music.
And although I'm not a troubadour
myself, I never really studied,
but the same thing
applies to the alguinaldo,
which are the two major genres.
You have the seis, and then
the alguinaldo also has
to have its own rules and
regulations where you can only sing
on one sentence or one
line a certain amount
of syllables per word,
per sentence, per line.
And every other sentence has
to rhyme in a certain way.
And a lot of people don't know this.
There's actual rules
and regulations --
formally singing this
music and playing.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Do they
still use the term espinela?
>> Gabriel Muñoz: Exactly, espinela.
That's where the inspiration
comes from
and the concept to sing the sies.
>> Daniel Sheehy: You play lots of
different kinds of seises, right?
Seis means six, but it's
kind of a genre that --
>> Gabriel Muñoz: Yeah.
Under each category, there's --
wow hundreds maybe of seis in
different styles alguinaldos.
>> Daniel Sheehy: And what
other genres do you play?
We have alguinaldos.
We have sies....
>> Gabriel Muñoz: Alguinaldos
and seis.
Then there's the bomba y
plena, which is also typical
of Puerto Rico, but more of the
African influence in Puerto Rico
with the conga drums and
everything like that.
Yeah. The cuatro and guitar were
added on to the bomba y plena
for melody and singing to
accompany, but that style of music
in all genres have
the African influence
which is something
we're very proud of.
We enjoy playing bombas and plenas
and stuff and things like that
when we get together as a group.
Everyone enjoys -- those
are really upbeat, festive,
danceable songs or styles.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Do you hang with
pleneros in New Jersey and New York?
There are a lot of
[inaudible] there.
>> Gabriel Muñoz: We've had the
privilege of performing once
or twice with a couple of groups.
But we haven't had the honor of
actually being able to hang and meet
with someone where we
can sit down and say --
to work on, let's collaborate
on something.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Lots
of potential there.
>> Gabriel Muñoz: Yeah, exactly.
>> Daniel Sheehy: And so what else?
Do you play the dansa?
You play the mazurka.
What are some of the other?
>> Gabriel Muñoz: There's
also paseo [spelling?].
We can do a paseo.
There's that style.
I do -- I'm not going to really say
because I'm not certain what South
American country the paseo has
influenced Puerto Rico, but
it has become so popular
and also become a standard in styles
of music of the Puerto Rican cuatro,
and there's a cuatro player by the
name of Eddie Lopez in Puerto Rico
who has also composed
many, many songs; of whom,
which Edwin Colón Zayas has been
influenced -- influenced by.
And there's a paseo that he plays.
Eddie Lopez composed many years
ago, and it goes like this
so you can get the
understanding of the rhythm.
It goes.
[ Music ]
So on and so forth.
But you get the concept
behind the idea.
>> Daniel Sheehy: I see
you get lost in that.
>> Gabriel Muñoz: I do.
But yeah, see the rhythms
change on guitar
and so every rhythm is a different
influence from a different country,
I would say, that somehow somewhere
or another has become a standard
for how cuatritas play in Puerto
Rico and how they compose music.
>> Daniel Sheehy: So just to
round off the different kinds
of music valse, you
mentioned a valse.
>> Gabriel Muñoz: Valse.
Yeah, there's a valse that Edwin
Colón Zayas made very popular,
one of his own inspirations
and compositions.
[ Music ]
I believe he even named it
after one of his daughters.
[ Music ]
So you have that rhythm too
for valse, which is gorgeous.
I mean, it's such an exquisite
rhythm and style of playing.
>> Daniel Sheehy: It is.
What else is there?
Is there something
marimba [spelling?]?
>> Gabriel Muñoz: There is marumba.
There's chacarar [spelling?].
Guaracha is one of
our favorite styles.
I mean, that's -- let's do
"Flamboyan" guaracha will give you
a quick snippet of -guaracha is one
of the most popular
danceable styles,
and there's a real famous song
made popular many years ago
in Puerto Rico named "El Flamboyan,"
which is beautiful fiery red tree
that exists in Puerto Rico, and it
is -- a certain cuatro player many,
many years ago inspired by that
also composed a fiery song for it,
entitled it after the tree, which
is called the flamboyan tree.
It goes like this.
[ Music ]
And so on and so forth.
So, it's a danceable, upbeat
type style known as guaracha .
That's also popular.
Early 1900s that really took off the
guaracha style and you would hear
that in all dance halls and parties
and people would always dance
and ask for guaracha
so they could dance.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Beautiful rhythm.
You're tapping your foot.
Tempo....
>> Gabriel Muñoz: You can't help
but feel that rhythm, you know?
That style.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Now,
you're a composer as well.
What sorts of pieces do you compose?
>> Gabriel Muñoz: Yeah.
I'll be honest with you.
My compositions and
inspirations come very rare.
I don't sit at home
composing every week.
In the almost 25 years, around
25 years I've been playing,
I might have composed five
or six songs, if that.
But it has to be something
major that takes
over me emotionally obviously
to move me to a musical piece.
And I've had the honor of composing
a dansa, which I performed today;
a mazurka, which I also performed
today; a joropo and so on.
I've even composed a guaracha and a
prelude, because of being inspired
by the classical movement on the
Puerto Rican cuatro, and so I guess
like any other musician, you get
an inspiration from somewhere.
Mine just don't come that
quickly, but when they do,
I try to take advantage
of it and try
to compose the best piece possible
that'll resonate throughout the
years because I also
understand that it's something
that will last for years.
I hear songs from the 1940s,
1950s by Ladi, for example,
and they still feel timeless and
so when I do get an inspiration,
I try to follow that idea.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Yeah.
You didn't compose and
seises or aquinaldos.
What's that?
>> Gabriel Muñoz: I know --
it's funny you mention that.
Being that I was born in the town of
Twetado, [spelling?] in Puerto Rico,
I always wanted to compose some type
of seis, [inaudible] or aguinaldo,
and I just -- I guess
I'm taking my time
because I don't want to copy anyone.
There's so many out there.
You think you compose something
and someone already did it.
So I'm trying to take my time
with how I'm going to do this
so that it'll be my own inspiration.
>> Daniel Sheehy: By the way,
did you ever meet Emilio Rosado,
the National Heritage Fellow?
>> Gabriel Muñoz: No I didn't.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Craftsman.
[Inaudible].
Instrument makers.
They're just some great
crafts people in Puerto Rico;
in the United States, as far
as that goes making the cuatro.
Who made yours?
Who are some of the ones
that you gravitate to?
>> Gabriel Muñoz: Like you
said, there are so many of them.
I started basically at the bottom
with the simple cuatro my father
bought from someone off the street
for $50, and I remember when I
first got inspired at the age of 14,
I said, "Dad, when I turn
15 for my 15th birthday,
I would like a cuatro
so I can learn."
And my Dad walked in on my 15th
birthday with a black trash bag,
and in it was this
cuatro cracked already
because of the years weighing on it,
and with that cuatro I learned --
I don't know who made it or
where it came from, but --
and to this day, I still have
that cuatro at home, by the way.
I look at that cuatro and I remember
why I started, and so I've come
to learn and meet so many great
luthiers and cuatro makers.
This one in particular: I was after
this gentleman for several years.
His name is -- he's known
as Manuel Feneque Rodriguez.
He's from a town called Rincón in
Puerto Rico, which is very far west
of the island near the beach and --
>> Daniel Sheehy: Kind
of a corner....
>> Gabriel Muñoz: Yeah.
Kind of in a corner.
Exactly.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Rincón
meaning corner.
>> Gabriel Muñoz: Yeah, exactly.
Rincón meaning corner.
Exactly. And so I was after him for
a couple of years and I had to be
on a waiting list, I
think, for about three,
four years to get an
instrument from him.
I've run through so
many different luthiers.
We're never satisfied.
We're always looking for the next
best guitar, next best cuatro.
You want something of quality,
obviously, to last you many years.
Sometimes it's just preference.
And so I just felt it was a point
in my life in time where I can go
to the next level and try to
acquire a good quality instrument.
When I heard from Mr.
Feneque, I contacted him.
He said, "Well, there's
a waiting list.
I can put you on it.
Call me next year, if
I have an opening."
And I kept calling him every year
from that moment on, and it took me
about four years to
get one from him.
He makes great quality instruments,
great quality and great sound.
>> Daniel Sheehy: So you
had to wait a year to call
to get on the waiting list?
>> Gabriel Muñoz: Every --
I would call him every year.
He said call me next year.
If I have an opening,
I'll let you know.
So he called me after like the
third or fourth year and said,
"Listen, a client backed out.
I have a cuatro I made for him.
Now he backed out for
whatever reasons.
If you like the instrument,
it's yours.
If not, then I'll have
to make one for you.
I'll send you photos of it."
I wasn't really content
with what I saw I saw,
not because it wasn't
a great instrument.
I already -- in my mind I envisioned
colors, shapes and what I wanted.
So I was able to say, hey, this
is what I kind of really wanted.
He said, "Well, give
me about six months --
it takes about six months to do.
I don't fabricate numbers,
mass fabrication.
I work on two, maybe
three an entire year."
That way he puts all his heart
and soul into it in detail.
And six months turned into a
year, and it was finally done.
He took his time, and I was more
than content, more than happy
when I opened the case and saw it.
That's another thing.
I don't know what I'm going to get.
I'm over here.
It's different if I'm over there
with him, and I can say okay,
this is how I want it to look.
I want that wood.
I want this sound.
But I didn't know what I was going
to get until I opened the case.
And I feel in love with it.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Is that
cedar, mahogany or what is that?
>> Gabriel Muñoz: What's
that -- the back?
>> Daniel Sheehy: This side.
This side, yeah.
>> Gabriel Muñoz: The side
-- this is actually rosewood.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Rosewood?
Okay.
>> Gabriel Muñoz: Yeah.
This is --
>> Daniel Sheehy: So
that's your request, right?
>> Gabriel Muñoz: Yeah.
Rosewood -- Brazilian rosewood,
which was aged for 20 years.
And I think an English spruce
top, was aged for ten years.
And so everything that he does
it's climate controlled wood,
climate controlled
work that he does,
aged so that you get a
good quality instrument.
Not a lot of people are doing that.
Yeah, the arm rest also.
This is a nice little detail.
Obviously, this concept
comes from classical guitars.
When people sit down and
play classical guitars,
they'll place their forearm to
play, which is a proper form
of interpreting the
classical guitar,
which is technically not the
same applies to the cuatro.
A lot of times when we're
playing, it's up here.
Such a small instrument
to begin with.
You're up here.
But sometimes I like to sit down
and interpret my pieces like that.
So this is something that is
one of his signature things,
on a cuatro he'll place an arm rest.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Interesting.
So getting back to New Jersey a
little bit: Who do you play for?
Who's the people in the
audience and what are they doing?
Are they sitting there
listening to you?
Are they dancing?
What -- tell us about that.
>> Gabriel Muñoz: I guess
that depends on what type
of venue or event it may be.
Predominantly, again, it goes
back to what I was saying earlier.
A lot of people love to
hear the festive stuff.
People listen to this instrument
and like what you guys head today
on stage with us performing.
A lot of it is just danceable
music and people want us to come
to a party or graduation or
wedding reception and play.
It makes me -- now that you
mention it, it makes me go back
to Ladi's days where if there was a
party, people would ask for dansas.
People would ask for
his compositions.
That was the danceable music
of that time, the dansas,
the formal type ballroom dancing,
and mazurkas and valses and things.
Nowadays, it's different.
Now with the modern times and all,
this instrument has to try to keep
up and so with all the different
genres and styles out there,
now we find ourselves playing a
lot of more of the danceable music.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Do you
play any Jimmy Hendrix?
>> Gabriel Muñoz: No, actually --
>> Daniel Sheehy: What's some
of the wild stuff you might do?
Even for fun?
>> Gabriel Muñoz: I think
we've experimented with
"Hotel California" before.
We've even tried to
experiment and delve
into the Cuban style music also.
I get some of my influences from
Cuban style music, the Cuban tres,
which is their folklore guitar.
And I try to adapt some
of that to the cuatro.
>> Daniel Sheehy: So
who are the audiences?
Are they all Boricuas?
Are they all anybody?
>> Gabriel Muñoz: The
majority, yeah.
Most of the time it is
fellow countrymen and people
from Puerto Rico that just want to
have our music and such like that.
We -- I do have to mention -- I
absolutely love the opportunity
to perform for not Puerto
Ricans, for other cultures,
because it's my opportunity to teach
about the instrument
and things like that.
This instrument isn't as popular
as some of us think it is.
You go to certain areas and
countries within Europe,
and they've never seen this thing.
And so I love the chance and
opportunity to say, "hey,
did you know about this instrument,
where it's from, how it sounds?
" And maybe try to get them to
kind of follow with the sound.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Somebody might
say you must be from -- cuatro --
that must be from Venezuela
or something like that
because the famous instrument
there, Colombia or whatever.
What -- so what -- what's
your neighborhood like?
Are you in a Puerto
Rican neighborhood or --
where do you -- what's your -- ?
>> Gabriel Muñoz: The city I grew
up in Trenton is more
of an urban setting.
There are a lot of minorities.
A lot of -- I noticed the
past ten, fifteen years,
a lot of Puerto Ricans have migrated
out of Trenton to different areas.
I have the privilege of knowing
two cuatro players that still stay
and live in Trenton so we can
get together from time to time,
kind of share inspiration,
ideas and such.
>> Daniel Sheehy: How do
you fit this into your life?
Are there other jealousies
out there that want your time?
>> Gabriel Muñoz: No.
Actually, this is it.
Yeah, this is it....
>> Daniel Sheehy: 24, 7?
>> Gabriel Muñoz: I mean, I do have
a full time job, but any moment,
any breathing moment I can, I'm
sitting down with this thing trying
to figure out where it's
going to take me next.
>> Daniel Sheehy: What do
you do in your full time job?
Police officer?
>> Gabriel Muñoz: I'm actually a
humane law enforcement officer,
humane police officer.
So for the past almost 20 years
I investigate animal cruelty.
That's something that I've
always been passionate about.
That's why I've been here so long.
It's something that I love doing.
Not anything that I was focusing on
doing, just kind of fell into it,
but fell in love with it
and been there ever since.
It's such a rewarding job.
And so it's kind of
strange because I come home
and then I sit down with this.
It's a whole different world.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Actually,
one of the reasons I asked is
because I knew someone
who was a police officer,
and he was a salsa flutist,
and so he would go shut himself
in his car and practice it.
I just wondered if you do the same.
>> Gabriel Muñoz: Yeah.
In my earlier years, I would take
my -- one of my lower-end cuatros.
I didn't want to damage my
good ones, but I would take one
of my cuatros to work with me to
headquarters and just practice
because I would have -- I
don't read or write music.
Everything I do is mostly by ear.
And so when I would get one of my
inspirations for my compositions
for example, I have to sing it
all day so I wouldn't forget
so I would take my cuatro
with me, and I'll play the
or dansa I'll play the
mazurka over and over and over
so I won't forget it
on my lunch break,
and until the song is complete,
it would take me several weeks.
Sometimes I will start a
composition, leave it alone,
step back and try to listen to it
from afar and wonder what I'm doing.
Is it going in the right direction?
Is it going to have the same
inspiration when I'm done?
So on and so forth until
the piece is complete.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Yeah.
Those two pieces you played have
a beautiful sentimentality to it,
an elegance to it, well
thought out kind of feel.
Really nice.
Has anyone else ever
played your compositions
or is it too challenging for them?
>> Gabriel Muñoz: My pieces
aren't really that complex.
I mean, they're -- my pieces
are predominantly simple.
I have heard one or two cuatro
players try to interpret some
of my songs and ask
if they can play them.
And by all means, that's
what it's here for.
I'm not picky or -- but I would
say stingy about my pieces.
Anyone wants to learn my
songs, more power to them.
It's there for that reason
so it can keep going.
I want to be able to grow old
and many years later hear one
of my songs and say I'm
glad that I was able
to inspire this one
particular person.
Maybe that one song was the one song
that person wanted to hear needed
to hear to get an inspiration to
continue playing and learning.
>> Daniel Sheehy: On the
topic of growing old,
we're here in the Library
of Congress.
And certain institutions
in this town, Washington,
D.C. think a long time ahead.
So we're right now -- this
will be part of the archives.
This is part of the
collections here.
And I assume it'll be
here for 50, 100, 200,
whatever hundreds of
years there might be.
What right now -- do
you have anything
that you think people should know a
hundred years from now or 200 years
from now or whatever about your
music, about you, about the group
or what part of American
society you are?
No pressure.
>> Gabriel Muñoz: Not at all, right?
Not at all.
Wow.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Even if something
frivolous -- whatever it might be.
>> Gabriel Muñoz: Yeah, I would want
-- obviously, I would want the music
and the culture of
the music to flourish.
I'm at a point right now in
this time in era and generation
where the cuatro has grown a lot.
It has continued to evolve,
and I'm seeing it grow,
although in a small community that
it is, I am seeing it growing.
And I just -- I hope that it
continues and continues to grow.
It's flourishing very well now,
and I want that to keep on going
and eventually until the cuatro
is basically fully mainstream
as it would be - as a
guitar is or a piano.
I want this instrument to
somehow revolutionize the music
of Puerto Rico.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Well, they
say that right now what one
out of six people who live in
the United States are Latino.
So as the demography moves
ahead, it could in a way happen
in a very organic sense combined
with beauty of your music
and also changing demography
of the United States.
That's the kind of thing
that I think about.
Who are the Ladis now
for the future?
Or who are the Lead
Bellys -he was like 1940's,
the Woodie Guthries
from way back then?
Looking ahead now, who are
they right now looking today?
>> Gabriel Muñoz: Who are they?
Where are they?
What are they doing?
And how will they change
the world as we know it
when it comes to the cuatro?
>> Daniel Sheehy: And that's
why we're interviewing you.
>> Gabriel Muñoz: We can only hope
and pray to be just a small ripple
and be able to inspire
other cuatro players.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Well, it takes
all the ripples getting together
to make things happen,
in my experience.
Could we round this off?
I can't resist the temptation
to see if there's a [inaudible]
in there somewhere because you
were all over that fingerboard.
You're all over that thing.
And that I assume was
all improvised.
Have some basic ideas that you
kind of remember over and over,
but that was really played out in
a very special way at that moment.
Just so people can go away
with their jaws dropped.
[ Music ]
>> Daniel Sheehy: Bravo.
Well, what can I say?
>> Gabriel Muñoz: Thank you.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Well, as
I'm going to take a page
from what I heard you
say today in the concert
and say how grateful I am to have
the opportunity to play some part
in taking your life, your
music, Mr. Ortiz' life and music
out into the public sometime
now and in the future.
So thanks so much for
being a part of this.
>> Gabriel Muñoz: Thank
you for having us.
>> Daniel Sheehy: And
congratulations.
It's a real pleasure
to have you here.
So that's it.
Thank you.
>> Gabriel Muñoz: Awesome.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.